a bordo de este avión nuevo rescatados
245 personas evacuadas de Sudán
aterrizaron en Francia entre ellos
holandeses italianos y 195 franceses
todos aliviados de estar a salvo he
visto cadáveres en la carretera son
imágenes que tengo que quitarme de la
cabeza
también pienso mucho en los udaces
porque tenemos muchos amigos allí que se
han quedado lo que está pasando allí es
muy violento tienen una guerra que es
realmente muy muy violenta creo que es
inaudito dos ejércitos luchando entre sí
Esta evacuación es una de las últimas de
la operación Sagitario nombre que recibe
esta misión del ejército francés en
terreno los soldados tienen una última
tarea evacuar embargo al personal de la
ONU un consejo hemos decidido enviar
Esta fragata que está en terreno y que
también nos permitirá traer de vuelta a
Europa a Francia a un cierto número de
compatriotas
será la última etapa en Sudán el proceso
de evacuación de extranjeros se ha
acelerado durante el frágil y reciente
alto al fuego entre ellos también hay
población China
la mayoría de los ciudadanos chinos en
Sudán han sido evacuados en grupo hacia
países vecinos así que hasta ahora no
hemos recibido informes de víctimas
entre la población China
y a primera hora del día más de 1600
personas de unas nacionalidades fueron
recibidas en Arabia Saudita sanas y
salvas